what up y'all before we jump into this
juicy episode of UFC 292 in Boston
headlined by aljo versus Suga Sean
O'Malley welcome to the shop show this
episode of the shop show is brought to
you by my friends at DraftKings
Sportsbook you could win big with money
lines props parlays and so much more
with this Saturday's UFC 292 is going
down you got Suga you got freaking uh
aljo yatwele Amanda limos imacado Gary
versus Neil the gazelle magni Cheeto
Vera Pedro Munoz Chris Weidman Brad
Tavares this thing is stacked you can
watch the fights and make Bank bro right
now new customers can score 150 in bonus
bets instantly for betting just five
dollars on any fight you see Saturday
night download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app use the code shop show shab show
let's go chop show only at draftking
Sportsbook
gambling problem call 100 Gambler New
York call 8778 Hope and why or text Hope
and why that's 467-369 in West Virginia
visit
www.1800gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at Charlestown Races
all games regulated by the West Virginia
Lottery please play responsibly in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
Resort Kansas 21 or older in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and
state-specific responsible gambling
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply terms at
sportsbook.draftkings.com baseball terms
six boys
what is up fam Monday morning how are
you guys everybody good great grand
wonderful fresh off the plane from
Phoenix Arizona it is hot out there not
gonna lie to you it's hot that over I
think 30 or 40 days of 120 degrees
weather some crap like that it's insane
insane didn't mind the heat though love
Phoenix chin finally got to try JT's
wings oh dude it lived up to well you
said it's so good you got to get the
works though
oh it was called works it's called The
Works I think it's just the works means
it's all their sauces on one oh but they
deep fry them like every wing place you
ever been to but then they Grill them
then they toss that fire sauce on it how
good is it chin it dude it reminded me
of Korean Fried Chicken but they do the
same kind of stuff that's why I loved it
a lot oh that makes sense yeah because
you guys uh do the similar like multiple
times yeah oh wow so it's not like uh
JT's Wing thing it's more of a Korean
thing what do you mean no no I mean
reminding me of Korean wings so but did
they steal that no I don't technique it
must be an old school culture
appropriation you never know all right
well I'll tell you what JT's Wings could
use is more staff
that poor lady who's one and it's packed
it's packed it's about the size of this
studio like this studio not the entire
thick boy this studio it's packed and
some just one waitress just doing things
just just uh
food's fantastic though yeah uh yeah I
love Phoenix man absolutely loved it uh
all the boys came out for the show on
Friday at stand up live on my favorite
clubs we had to sahuto there Kelvin
gaslin Corey sander Hagen
uh am I freaking Fighters there what
other way to break me or his wife of
course Frank Mayer his wife was there
um I feel like we had some other guys
trying to think that locker room was I'm
the locker room Green Room
wiener Festival a lot of dudes in there
dude a lot of dudes it's a great time
though
um I feel like we're forgetting somebody
I might have it on my camera oh yeah you
were chin was uh vlogging thing Jim was
on it too man he was like how you
feeling bro come on man come on dude and
then you went to the UFL fights with me
because I that's why I did just one show
on Friday because UFL who I'm uh working
with is uh they're based out of Mesa
where they do all their fights so they
had their big fight card there I'm gonna
fight well I went to one championship
before that I haven't been a fight in a
hot second good night of fights fun
fights good great production you had
Rampage son fighting Raja Raja uh raja's
vegan and that's why Rampage thinks he
lost he did lose by decision I think
it's uh I didn't agree with the
matchmaking they gave him a pretty good
wrestler
um first first pro fight which is it's
just a lot for a kid in his first pro
fight so
um but overall the Knight of fights were
great I saw a bunch of my old buddies CB
dollaway who's Arizona's finest uh Joey
Villa Sonora he's trained with that
Jackson's good I haven't seen him in
Forever he he used to be a nightmare to
spar he was so awkward uh UFC vet there
him and Keith Jardine were super close
love both those guys
uh yeah just saw everybody man there's
so many people there uh Ed Herman my boy
Ed Herman he was coaching Corey
sanderhagen had a guy fighting his guys
in the finale
um there's just a ton of ton of people
and then I'm trying to think oh and then
I got to hang out with uh Chris Angel
what
yeah oh [__] damn Jim was drinking so he
missed all this but Chris Angel party
you know you didn't see Chris Angels so
at the you probably disappeared what
UFL or the green Irma the UFL man he was
all over the only guy that looked like a
magician and I was sitting right behind
you basically so I probably talked to
him for 30 minutes you can't see any of
that so is he sitting next to you then
nah man he came over and we two
literally stand and talk about 30
minutes I was hanging out with Ben and
probably just and then there and then
there's a there's a guy named so there's
Shannon Briggs who's the boxer right
yeah let's go champ Shannon Briggs
there's a guy named Shannon Rich who's
like old school MMA guy I think he has
the most fights in the history of MMA
and Shannon rich
somehow thought I was talking stuff
about not talking stuff but was making
fun of them I don't know how it happened
but he was talking he goes hey man I
thought we were cool a bunch of my guys
sent me stuff said you were talking
stuff I was like uh and you know to be
fair I've never maybe I've heard of him
but I'm not too familiar with his work I
know I know he has all the fights in the
world but I think it got the lines got
crossed because I was talking about
Shannon Briggs not Shannon Rick very
similar very very that was the only
thing I could think when he was talking
about and he's not a great guy nice guy
had a lit ass outfit on too but um
really nice guy he's like yeah man it
bothered me man they said you were you
know knocking on me or roasting me I was
like you sure it's not Shannon Briggs
but we squashed the beef he was a nice
guy I don't think there's any beef he's
a good dude cool he has all the fights
go to his record
yes I mean he has all the fights
this guy fights for straight up a living
it was like his records something crazy
dude
so he first of all he had how many
fights told that base 69 151 matches so
he's a 151 fights
151 fights 58 wins
um they still I mean he's still doing it
dude he can't be that old he I mean
young yeah he's like 50 or something but
he's 52. but his background you're
talking about a legit badass like listen
to his background so uh Rich was born
he's Arizona's finest was raised dirt
poor uh rich man learning karate from a
young age
um
became a professional kickboxer this is
in the 80s
um
yeah he was in Blackwater
Jesus is deployed in Kuwait Iraq
Afghanistan
he has black belt
um yeah dude you're talking about like a
real legit badass in Blackwater I want
no problems with this man third degree
black belt black belt and karate
yeah it has a hundred
he has two thousand fights okay
you're a nice guy did he find Pride go
down and find Pride he said dude he is a
prototypical pride fighter yeah old
school
uh yeah five uh tips
against something
Jesus Rich lost Achilles locked
submission a minute into the fight right
um
nakamara that's submission huh yeah he's
fought all over King the cage of course
they used to be huge in Arizona whoa
generator hey what is this in 2018
Shannon took part in an event promoted
by UFC fighter Brad or taking place in
Rush with no audience no ring no cage
the card feature may event with women
taking on a map okay hold on hold on
feature a main event with a woman taking
on man and mixed martial arts
winners suppose he's taking a million
dollar purse Rich opened the card in a
heavy about against professional
wrestler Jerry Myers
don't say anything if the woman won or
not because he I thought you were saying
he fought a woman
interesting is it storied career though
Blackwater yeah real real legit badass
bare knuckle but of course he did bare
knuckle Jesus Christ
he won the fight via knockout 26 seconds
first round
then he's wrestling Japan wrestling
everything God Todd what hasn't this guy
done
come on he goes he does acting
you thought I was busy this dude is
oh dude he was in Walker Texas ring
it's a legend dude CSI
and dude golfing
oh what's up Casey you think you're good
at golf
he took first place in many state and
Pro-Am competitions
they might put something heavy on you
man and left away that freaking crazy
fighting sport well what's that it's
like it's bare fisted elbows I think
head butts too and everything this guy
don't give up
wow
good good guy though nice guy he was
cool cool
yeah he was cool shout out to UFL thanks
for having us how was it grand old time
so my boy Tiki the manager for every
yeah that's it I saw them too and I also
Tracy Cortez how much did you drink
we drink she was like wait I was at a
fight in Phoenix yeah
yeah he saw Tracy Cortez that's one of
my favorites yeah she's great Tiki doing
the damn thing Ben Henderson Ben
Henderson's wife is like the
what would you call she like the
operational manager she was running
around like Joe Silva but also just
doesn't do matchmaking puts a whole
event together she has like a twin
sister too right there's like someone
else I didn't know they were twins
because the one so there's Ben
Henderson's wife right she was in jean
shorts and hanging out with Ben all the
fighters over there
and then there's her twin sisters the
operational manager who's like dressed
up because obviously he's running the
event and I know they're twins and then
she laughed and not you know whatever I
was talking probably freaking uh Chris
Angel who's such a good dude and you
don't really sell Rich Chris Angel is
broke horse man dude 70 million a year
for magic he's been doing since 2005.
wow
I know I was like uh
uh you need like an assistant or
something you wanna like cut me in half
dude I used to do that too what to pick
up girls the game I started learning
magic and it actually works in that book
says speak of magic
God Dodge there's better things in the
book but that's one of the things and it
works in a nightclub at a bar yeah
yeah you do that
boy I feel like if you had to pull off
magic in a nightclub maybe it's just not
I know sometimes it's just like what's
behind your ear she's like oh my God
don't touch me he's like sometimes
they're like it's a quarter it's like
who has changed this day and age
Chin's like who's your card ten of
Spades she's all no no no it's I'm sorry
what
you're like Oh I thought you said 10 of
space she's not a ten of Hearts seems
like a nightmare God if you have to
learn magic to get chicks dude it was
one of the techniques let's get a tattoo
on your face for The Conversation Piece
yeah magic or take Andrew Tate's class I
feel like that would that no that would
that didn't exist like that's more
beneficial yeah
how did you learn that and yeah when
you're like do you want to see each
other they're like no I'm like okay hell
no I walk away your head down the dark
guards dude creepy that isn't Club hey
you in the magic uh hard ass hard pass
joke I'll show you guys later yeah I
would love to see that chin did it ever
work for you yeah sometimes it'd work
how so what's Define work uh so just
actually getting her number and going on
a date afterwards oh really some are
just so entranced by Magic it's so crazy
like some are just super into it are you
sure girls are so you know they they
want to believe in like you know crazy
[__] so it just makes you seem like
you're like just an amazing person don't
you think you could just like watch
Ghost Adventures and like talk like some
ghost ship with them
yeah I'll show you or even like uh like
knowing like all the the like what year
were you born what you know what's your
sign yeah you there's there's magical
numbers too if I ask you to pick between
a certain amount of numbers I would
usually get the number because there's
like a thing that happens with people
they pick you know certain numbers if
you give them a bracket so if I said
pick a number between one and five you
got it yeah three my number was three
dude
I don't know dude
when you start learning magic
it's like oh God you took whatever some
guy's just really bad he's like I just
you know
you did right away
this is like a nice steakhouse
they're like please go she's like you're
the steak here's lost
oh my God
holy [__] that's lit dude I'm glad you
got that skill set Doug dude do the
magic in front of Chris Angel let me
know how it goes for you that dude it's
like a real magician
pick a number between one and three
two
what's up you want to go out tomorrow
night she's all no
this is creepy as [__] dude oh man
that's sick Chad I'm glad you learned
that yeah man well let's get right into
the fights
shout out to Chris Angel and Chin The
Magicians let's take a little break from
chat UFC 292 this Saturday in Boston all
right cause I am all hopped up on my
favorite product happy hippo that's
right however you want to get your happy
hippo we have powders we got gummies we
got instant shots we got the new K dips
yeah the first ever to Market pouches
with kratom in it that's the crowd of
Kratom Kratom extract pouches this is
the Wintergreen that's a Razzle Dazzle
it's the best Kratom it's the only crate
of my trust on this planet that's why I
asked them to be part of this program if
you want to try Kratom you got to get it
from somebody that you trust and that's
Happy Hippo go to happyhippo.com promo
code is thick23 you save 20 off
everything I mentioned the powders the
gummies the instant shots the energy
shots the K dips all of it you 20 off
you can use that for your entire life
share it with a friend that's a lifetime
promo code that's Happy hippo.com promo
code is thick with three C's 23 for 20
off now let's get back to the program
you'll see 292 is here kids it's in
Boston it's in Boston [__] shoot the
last time I went to UFC fight was in
Boston
I went to Francis zagano and Stipe where
uh steepe with weathered the storm with
just those freaking African bombs and
eventually won a fight against Francis
was which which was insane
but
this card is stacked take all my money
you got your Headliners Al Jermaine
Sterling Sean O'Malley sugar Sean we
know who the UFC's praying to God maybe
UFC's doing magic right now hoping sugar
Sean can pull this off because you know
they want nothing more than sugar Shawn
to get this when come Saturday night you
got waylay fighting Amanda Lemos you
know it's cool you got Neil magni late
replacement against Ian Machado Gary
tough fight for my boy Neil magni who I
named the gazelle but he changed his
name Cody garbrandt's off yep you have
Cheeto who's remember this car is
supposed to be stacked so it's still
good but you're supposed to have Cheeto
versus Henry sahuto
but sojudo uh is hurt says he's feeling
pretty good now though oh I also uh
Corey sanderhagen got the surgery he
said he's out six months not a year he's
out six months
so but he did he was in a slaying and
Corner guys with one arm
doing magic
um but you got Cheeto Vera versus Pedro
Munoz probably the best fight in the car
to be honest
uh Chris Weidman long waited return
against Brad Tavares two of my faves two
of the nice guys in the sport he'd see
any one of them lose they got Weidman
has a plus 210 dog
yeah against Tavares too which is kind
of I don't know as far as falling on
Hard Times too both these are straight
up vets I like the matchmaking here
though
you know I think the UFC is just like
yeah one of these gonna be gone you know
you want to see some magic check this
out one of you is gone
um and then you also got the Ultimate
Fighter finale Boys on there Austin
Hubbard and Kurt hollowball
that all and then one of my faves Andre
petrovski versus Gerald Mercer that's a
great fight
my boy Andre is a big fave at minus 290
almost minus 300.
uh Lee's on this fight on this card and
Andrea Elise on this card she had the
whole
oh yeah you know yep that whole
everybody knows uh the Austin Hubbard
and Kurt hollabaugh fight from The
Ultimate Fighter at what point did you
stop watching Ultimate Fighter after
episode one oh wow yeah I I stopped
watching it two episodes ago I missed
there there was like a great fight they
said it was like force versus uh Seth
and Bonner
um yeah Jason Knight oh I saw the
highlights of that that was freaking I
mean that was painful to watch too
though yeah
Yeah Austin Hubbard this is my whole
thing the entire
they they were set up for failure from
the jump you know having young kids on
versus veterans obviously all the Vets
are the only ones that moved on
um Michael challenge team dominated so
it kind of screwed him from the jump
and I think when that happens you know
it's just not intriguing you just don't
care also there's something to be said
about these young prospects that have
personalities coming up getting to the
UFC following their careers now it's
like you know Austin Hubbard's been in
the UFC Kurt Hall about they've been in
the UFC we've seen the Run there's
nothing enticing to stay along once they
beat all these young prospects these
these Savvy vets who've had to run the
UFC before it's like okay it's just not
exciting it's not a knock on us an
awesome Hubbard I hope he you know wins
the damn thing and goes on to have a
great career but he's kind of he's done
it so it's like all right so if he win
if he wins the finale he wins on
Saturday night
what do you do with them
you know you know because he has so many
fights you're not just going to toss
them you know young kids still is he
going to compete in the top 15
I don't know what you do with them but
it's cool to see these uh older cats get
a second chance at a career I just don't
the ceiling's not that high on it you
know so it doesn't make sense for fans
to follow along there's nothing
intriguing there to completely miss the
boat on that I thought the UFC did and
the producers who did it
probably the same producers that put
Michael Chandler and Conor McGregor in
the ice bath for two hours almost killed
both of them that's one of the events
Dana was not happy uh but this card
overall great card especially the main
card all of it's good you got Andre
petrovski on the freaking on the prelims
Austin Hubbard on the prelims
uh Gregory Rodriguez uh is wide I assume
one two three four yeah Whiteman kicks
off the main card let's go to the actual
UFC website let's see
the UFC website still has freaking I
know that's why I feel like they I don't
know if I have their website but
sometimes you think at the level that
they're at people would update the
website they still have Cody garbrand on
there
but it doesn't are you on Main card when
you click on go down usually it'll show
prelims and oh this one just says it
doesn't yeah it just goes straight I
would assume because look one two three
and this one yep doesn't count four five
yeah Whiteman kicks off the main card
so we start there you got Weidman Brad
Tavares uh both fallen on tougher times
Chris weidman's been up for a hot second
I think win loser draw this is weidman's
last fight I think he just wants to go
out on a high note uh click on his uh
his last few fights chin
so he's coming off the Uriah Hall leg
injury no one really comes back at full
health off this horrible leg injury
yeah he's following some tough times man
he's lost one two three four five six
of us last eight and then this leg
injury so I'd assume him coming back is
just him
you know proven to himself he doesn't
want to end on that note with that
horrible leg injury because he had a win
before that
um
man I like the matchups especially
against Brad Tavares
there's a reason he's a dog though but
I'm assuming because he's coming off and
Brad's coming off two losses you know
and he's lost four as last six he's
caught some tough guys though man
really tough guys he went to a decision
with du policies who's no punk obviously
we've learned that
then obviously he lost the Izzy lost the
shabazzian
duplicates Bruno Silva tough guys
you can see why Brad Tavares is the
favorite they've just thrown him to the
Wolves Doug he's fought everybody
it's tough not to root for Weidman
coming off this leg injury but Wyman
also said he wants to spend more time at
home with his kids and just kind of be
president be a dad so
um we'll see man but that's a good fight
100 that's a good fight
yeah so for to kick off the main card uh
I will take Chris Weidman I refuse to
bet against Chris Weidman even though I
love Brad Tavares I'll take Chris
Weidman via
TKO
he's a big dog for a reason but how can
you bet against Chris Weidman
All-American widemen
in his comeback from that yeah I just
want to see him do well I don't see
those guys lose but I'm gonna take Chris
Weidman just because it's Chris Weidman
uh Cheeto Pedro Munoz love both these
guys it's I think it's by far the best
stylist to fight on the main card uh
prior fight of the night
um Cheeto needs this win to stay in the
the hunt for the title as well there's
big implications across the board with
this
um let me see Pedro chin
get off that one against Chris Gutierrez
the Sean O'Malley fight Donald Cruz Les
Jose Aldo unless Frankie lost to aljo
already
I'll take Cheatham I think Cheeto gets
done with his uh his reach and his
striking definitely needs to avoid going
the ground with him and that Guillotine
of Pedros uh I'll take Cheeto I think he
gets it done via TKO remember too it's a
three-round fight so Cheeto might come
out like a banshee instead of so slow
like he's been doing lately and then
when my other favorite matchups on the
card you got Ian Machado Gary vs Neil
magni
um you know not not a I think it's a
good fight for if you're a big Ian Gary
fan who is kind of the pride of Ireland
right he's their next uh hope after the
Conor McGregor Fiasco he's kind of the
next man in line has all the skills to
get it done especially what he did how
well he performed in that Daniel
Rodriguez fight
um Neil's my boy but I will say this
um
you know Neil taking on short notice
cardio is never his thing he can go for
days it's just kind of a perfect matchup
for Ian Gary to Showcase his skill set
um I think he can get it done via
knockout which is either said than done
it's not a lot of guys knock out Neil
magni at all
um Neil magni's kind of big thing is uh
he's susceptible to getting submitted
whenever he fights a high level juice
guy he always loses now when it comes
again knocked out pontanibio did it
outside that it's tough to land it's
very tough to land now you could see Ian
Gary kind of implement the Lorenz Larkin
uh offense here where he was very
aggressive Neil does fight off his back
foot so you got to get him to the cage
and Gary has a skill set to get that
done I think you're gonna get a very
Lorenz Larkin performance out of Ian
Gary apply pressure which we don't see a
lot with uh Neil Magnum he usually out
points him stays on his back foot can
Circle the cage really well cardio for
freaking days that's what I call him the
gazelle but um it's a tough fight for
our boy Neil magni I think Ian Gary gets
it done moves up in the rankings and
he's Off to the Races man he gets a big
knockout here I do think he's gonna be
the Talk of the Town after this fight
if he and Gary can go out and perform
like he does
um and I'm big on the engagement he is a
straight stud
great skill set so uh I think Neil's
ranked 11 right now so for uh in gear I
think if he gets a highlight KO it will
give him the top 10.
um yeah Neil's 11. yeah
so this would be a big win for him
he's 13. yeah he's 13 that Jack uh jdm's
14.
he has some Young Bucks in there got
shot up there one boy still didn't have
a fight yeah I'm sure you have that in
the current events as far as him not
getting paid
but uh I I would have liked if he gave
me the keys to the to the arena out of
done in gay versus Wonder Boy
that would have really catapulted him up
to the top seven
I bet we see that fight but not this
year but early next year
um so yeah I'll take unfortunately I'm
betting against my guys here but
unfortunately I'll take in uh Machado
Gary talking to town I think he's gonna
be the MVP of the card you have
zhanguela versus Amanda limos
you know it's not long ago uh limo's
lost uh what in 2020 was that 20 or 21
she got kind of dismantled by Jessica
and Raj
um
you know her Jiu Jitsu game is suspect
her Advantage would be her power and her
her boxing over waylay but I do think
Whaley has she's just a better fighter
overall her skill set is
way more diverse I think waylay is going
to be smart I think she uses her
offensive wrestling gets her down and I
think she gets her out in the first two
rounds the good thing is these aren't
this whole main card's not gonna be a
boring decision card in any facet every
fight set up to be pretty freaking
exciting starting with wide win Tavares
that's gonna be a war Cheeto Pedro the
Spider-Man fight of the night in Gary
Neil magni I think Gary gets a highlight
KO way Amanda limos you're going to get
a good fight out of waylay there I think
she's going to be pretty aggressive and
get Amanda down uh Amanda could win she
has enough power to land one shot and
knock waylay out but wayle only loses to
one person one person only and her
name's Rose outside that she beats the
brakes off everybody including Mana
limos I'll take wayli she's a big
favorite so that's no surprise there
then your main event alge over sugar
shot O'Malley
listen aljo is a bad matchup for
everybody you know you'll hear around
other people do what I do in the
business go oh it's a nightmare matchup
for sugar Shawn Al Jermaine is a
nightmare for everybody in the division
with his skill set homeboy hasn't lost
and since when chin scroll down he
hasn't lost since 2018 and he's had some
fights man 17. 2017. yeah oh when he got
head kicked by Marlon Mirage
yeah with that knee that's bad since
then though he's beat everybody
everybody and I think too now what makes
aljo special is he knows what he's good
at when he gets your back he wears you
like your backpack there's nobody better
in the history of the UFC that once they
get your back and uh you know strangely
unconscious with a rare naked choke
that's where aljo Excel you know sells
there I do think
um
again he's a bad matchup for everybody
it's not a knock on uh sugar
but when you compare to compare what
these guys do great right obviously
sugar has such an advantage when it
comes to Stand-Up game but aljo has a
significant Advantage when it comes to
grappling the wrestling being the big
fights beating better opponents the
knock on sugar is his opponents right a
lot of his wins those guys aren't in the
UFC anymore one of the wins the guy
hasn't fought since he lost a Suga and
then with Suga you know the time he has
fought tough opponents in Cheeto you
know he did lose that fight
controversially he'd lost that fight and
then when he did finally got to Pedro
Munoz he had The Accidental eye poke so
we don't know and then when he stepped
up to the big plate against Peter yawn
stylistically in the top three it was
the best matchup form and I thought he
did beat Peter Young straight up I
thought he beat Peter John I think that
shut up a lot of the haters that had
that knock on sugar he hasn't beat
anybody he can't compete at the highest
level he beat Peter John man and when it
was Prime Peter yawn like he beat a damn
good Peter Young Peter hasn't been the
same since so I I think Suga is
undervalued I think people you know
the knock on him is the UFC Watson B
Champion so they're giving the easy path
let me clear all this up guess the UFC
does give certain guys passes because
you know sugar is a huge name huge name
it comes with a massive younger audience
and it is an advantage to the UFC if he
becomes Champion the UFC can only do so
much and eventually you're gonna have to
fight guys like Al Joe or Peter yon if
you don't pass the test they can't after
that there's nothing to do now get into
that point in the UFC accelerate your
path to get to the title shot or get to
the top five of course they did with
Alex pierra but uh paid off the guy's a
Savage do you not want to see him fight
you know he's a massive name in the
light heavyweight he right away he
fights young former champ beats him nice
fight for a title are you mad at it I'm
not now did he take the same path of
resistance as you know a Tony Ferguson
or you know some of these other guys
Dustin Poirier you know a Max Holly
who's fought everybody a Cheeto Vera
strength of schedule is pretty damn good
you know you look at all these guys that
you know Pedro Munoz fought everybody
you know it's just the UFC can only do
so much where at the end of the day you
have to be able to beat these guys that
aren't perfect matchups was not a
perfect matchup for sugar and sugar past
that test so I get the the where the
haters will push back and go he hasn't
found anybody he has he thought Peter
Yan he beat him so that doesn't work
here Alger is a nightmare of a matchup
he is but he's a nightmare for everybody
in the division so there's that and you
know
would the UFC want sugar to win this
fight of course he's a massive star if
he wins this makes him even bigger
there's nothing the UFC can do Saturday
night there's nothing they do to
increase his grappling capabilities
against aljo and even if he was a good
Grappler
um he's no algo aljo's so damn good you
guys aren't giving enough credit why
alja doesn't get the credit he deserves
I blows my mind I have no idea why the
Peter yawn fights whatever just look at
what he's done even before that look
what he did to TJ yeah but TJ had one
arm okay still dismantled him look I did
the koi Santa Hagen where's your excuse
on that one Corey's damn good top three
in the world he dismantled coin not even
competitive now if they fight again I
think it's a different story a more
competitive fight does Corey beat him I
don't know
but still liquidity decoy look into
Henry sudo what's your what's the excuse
with Henry sahuto well Henry Sue is over
the hill he didn't you know ring rust
okay he still beat Henry sahuto if not
top two greatest combat athletes of all
time beat him he also took him down
that's how freaking good album algo is
at grappling his wrestling's good is
jitsu's phenomenal his striking could
definitely use some work and I think
that's why people try to lean towards
sugar here but
um
you know I I think if sugar brings his a
game aljo brings his a game aljo's gonna
win that fight nine times out of ten
because of the way the rules are set up
because of the way the sport is set up a
great Grappler will usually always be a
good Striker if the strikers no not even
close to the same level of grapple it's
just the way it goes because the
grappler dictates where the fight goes
there's nothing sugar can do and I saw
an interview sugar had with Brad akamoto
where he goes I have to be perfect I
have to be perfect I know I'm getting
taken down but just about surviving on
the ground when I heard that that when
him say survive I'm like oh I don't like
that
I don't like that I don't think you can
survive on the ground with Al Joe I
think it's only a matter of time before
he gets you down now it's different it's
Galley Kenny sohudu who has a great
wrestling background great wrestling
bass and get back to his feet and then
aljo can you know mix up the strike and
and secure the takedowns with Suga it's
gonna be tough for him to just survive
down there I don't like that word
survive hoping that they either stand
you up or you don't get submitted in the
round ends then you start back on your
feet because then you're looking at
every single round you look at maybe a
30 45 second Gap where you can maybe
land a glance and blow now Suga does
have knockout power you know crazy
knockout power so if he does land one
but again
so who do at his bet I'm sorry aljo at
his best should get his best Sterling to
win that fight I think both of them do
bring their a game Saturday night I just
think it's Sterling's time and I do
think once Sterling leaves and goes up
to 145 and you know tries to take on
Alex wilkinowsky which is another story
we'll get to that when it happens but
um aljo is big for the division he's the
strongest guy in the division his most
skills on the division here's the
experience he's that extra Championship
mentality he's just impossible to beat
right now but when he leaves I think it
could definitely be suga's division
because as good as marab is I don't
think he's as versed as aljo aljo's
special man morabi you know what you're
getting I think Suga has a better chance
against morale than does aljo I think
sugar has a better chance against Henry
suhuto I think does aljo you know and
Corey sandhagen sugar is a great fight
um so yeah I I just think even if sugar
loses it doesn't do much now if he goes
in and gets starched in the first round
gets taken down and you know strangled
in 40 seconds yeah it might hurt his
streak red a little bit but I think
despite even if sugar loses fight which
I do think he does if he does lose this
fight
um I think he'll be fine because alja's
gonna jump up and wait what she says
he's wanting to do and they have marab
you have Henry sahuto Corey sandhagen at
the top I think sugar matches up well I
do think suga's gonna be Champion just
not Saturday night I love sugar has all
the skills in the world so exciting do
you have to get definitely use him as a
champion the problem is you have alja at
the top of the hill right now and that's
impossible for anyone including Suga
including marab including Henry sahuto
including Corey sanhagen
including Cheeto
Sterling's just that damn good you got
to give him his flowers man he's that
damn good so uh tough night in the
office for not just sugar it's not
knocked on sugar but for anyone in that
division it's gonna be tough for Sean to
get done unless and I hate when people
say lucky Punch or lucky there's no luck
the guy trains his ass off but if if
aljo takes his eye off the price for one
second which he usually doesn't but if
he does she'll put his lights out you're
betting on that
I'm gonna put money on that but um I
like both guys but I just think aljo's
that damn good I'll take aljo for this
one so I am taking
I'll take us in Hubbard I'll take my boy
Andre petrovski I will take uh Chris
Weidman clearly we'll never bet against
Cheeto Vera I'll take Ian Machado Gary
sorry Neil magni and all the Heil two
boys I'll take waylay and I'll take Al
Joe
the only dog I'm taking is Chris Weidman
and that's just because Chris Weidman
I'm not saying bet on that but you never
know
fun out of fights though man yeah
it'd be crazy if sugar wins though it'd
be great
it'd be incredible yeah it'd be insane
it's a tough task man yeah especially
right now aljo is freaking he's in his
prime man it's his time that's how this
goes
what do you got Jed all right so the uh
so there's some uh rumors about what the
pay-per-view buys were for an ads versus
Jake Paul and I think one of them was
I forget about this title here but so
one of them was like 450 000 people
great that's not bad right that's
phenomenal and apparently Nick Diaz
according to his manager uh he made
around 15 to 20 million isn't that great
that's insane that's so great that's
more they made for any of the counter
fights people were arguing like oh but
the UFC paying the same nah he wasn't
getting 20 million for the counter
fights guarantee was it yeah
so this is my thing with Jake like you
guys want to hate on Jake but look what
he's doing for your favorite Fighters
look what he's doing Nate would have
never got this opportunity ever
especially he didn't take that much
punishment either he made 20 mil and
didn't really take any punishment and
then he's and not only that he still
looks cool in front of all yeah they
grew his name like
kudos to kudos to Jake man good for him
um so you mentioned this earlier we're
going to talk about it so the whole
Stephen Thompson not getting paid for
his show money and then Dana White
talked about it I think it was during
the contender series he just mentioned
like this is the process that we went
through like we try to give him another
fight right he didn't want to take the
fight he would have gotten the purse
like a chunk of the purse of the other
guy Michelle pajer and he didn't want to
take another fight so they tried to get
him another fight but he denied that
hold on that that same night they tried
to give him a different fight but
they're saying for another maybe like a
week or two later maybe oh and he don't
want to take that he didn't want to take
it and so Dana's like that's a two
that's half or sorry 250 000 right so if
he doesn't want to like take our options
like you can't just lose 250 000 I heard
the argument I'm like it makes more
sense but he also said that they want to
work with Stephen Thompson to pay for
his camp or whatever you know but as far
as not taking a fight or another fight
uh yeah as far as I'll tell you another
if I can get Dana's argument there this
is for the fighters the managers really
how in your contract do you not are do
you not demand if we make weight the
opponent doesn't we get our show money
no matter what how that's not in the
contract is inside I'm with you that
shouldn't be up for debate if no matter
what whether we take a fight or not
and whatever is 30 of the other Fighters
purchase 20 whatever it is but no matter
we shouldn't be in this weird awkward
position where we have to save the card
and obviously one boy Thompson has bad
history with this because he did this
with Darren till and lost via Split
Decision it ruins at 40 years old you
can see why I didn't want to do it now
that being said this where I side with
Dan because he's like well we did off
from a fight like two weeks later he's
clearly in shape made the weight now
made the way
and I know people go it's only three
pounds so three pounds are by far the
worst part of the business those three
pounds right separate the the contenders
from the the Champions that's what it is
those three pounds are a nightmare for
them to cut it's everything so when I
got when you see a guy come in just
three pounds over and you go it's only
three pounds no no those three pounds
won't drain your energy that yeah that
give you you makes you a little chinny
makes you a little slower makes you
exhausted those three pounds are the
killer pounds so the guys that are
cutting weight like Wonder Boy no like
no those three pounds are everything
wait this guy gave up and he's three
pounds off oh that means it's a rough
cut and he doesn't want to go through
what I went through so I'm not going to
fight that guy because the three pounds
are the toughest to get and he's given
up and I went through it absolutely not
so it's smart that means and but then
remember one one boy I'm sure Abe put on
some weight and then I do it again in
two weeks so you cut two weeks then you
cut those horrible three pounds put on
weight then go back it's just not the
it's not the best way to do it
it's a nightmare and obviously Dana
doesn't understand that which I get why
Woody because he's never cut weight like
that
but I will argue with Dan here if you
did offer him a good fight like two
weeks later which I would assume it's
the the Ian Gary fight on this Saturday
that's what I would assume that's about
two weeks after
you don't want to do that Danny like
it's tough for me to pay the guy we
bought from all right you don't do that
we understood we got from a fight a big
name two weeks later it doesn't want to
do that
what are we paying for yeah he's like
well I I and which is one of the boys
argument and should be in the contract
yeah but I made weight
I didn't get anything went through a
whole Camp so
I get both sides I didn't know Wonderboy
turned out a fight two weeks later yeah
I didn't know either if I'm dating like
we gotta entice these guys to fight if
we just pay guys and they don't fight
what are we paying for
yeah but I also there could be a
case-by-case base too because
Wonder Boys I mean everyone loves Wonder
Boys this guy's been a staple of your
roster for how long you know he's down
to fight he's just being smart he's a
businessman and he's like dude I'm 40.
I'm ranked number seven in the world I
lose again I'm screwed there's no chance
I get big fights at 40. so I got to be
smart about this you'd think they would
understand that and go all right let's
just give them a show money also it's
not like you can't afford it again this
is Case by case I'm not saying to
introduce every time and it's up to the
managers and the fighters get together
and have this stipulation their
contracts and if we make weight and
we're ready we don't have to take a
fight we still get our show Money how
that's not in the contract is
mind-blowing that's their fight I'm not
going to deal with that but you would
think and I I get why Dan's like well if
guys just don't take fights and they
keep falling out and then we're screwed
so you don't want to encourage this but
when it comes to Wonder Boy come on man
it's Wonder Boy baby I know the nicest
guy yeah plus the two guys that freaking
didn't make weight are some of the
biggest guys in the division too Darren
Taylor was enormous massive gorilla yeah
Michelle Pierce so when they don't make
it again those three pounds it's every I
know to the common person's like three
pounds you've already cut like 15 I know
it's those last three that drain guys it
kills them those are the three hell
pounds
absolutely
all right so
Logan Paul is supposed to fight Dylan
danis in a boxing match October 14th in
Manchester this one's interesting you
know and I like both guys and Dylan
danis you know I do think he's a good
person you know has his issues the the
question here would be does Dylan show
up right because he kind of falls out
from fights there's a clause on that too
apparently six figure pull out penalty
if he fails to face Logan Paul I mean
good luck in that money if he has it but
the other thing is these kids these days
man like have you seen Dylan Dennis's
Savage response that's so hardcore yeah
Zealand dance goes full Savage on Logan
Paul Post picks a fiance with
ex-boyfriends and the picks are like
dude you would hate to see this about
your ex-girl
so who's the first one
uh
I know I think he's from One Direction I
think and then there's obviously
Leonardo DiCaprio which is this is not a
bad picture no this one sucks I hate I
don't like this
yeah who is that I don't know
but it's an ex-boyfriend I'm sure he's
some sort of celebrity in some way it
seems she only goes for the I mean she's
a dime so I get it would you care chin I
don't think I mean obviously you know
her past but I mean I don't want to see
this picture of my ex-girlfriend
that would bother me yeah I don't I
don't know if it'd bother me that much
if you're uh if you're low I mean I
guess Logan's on social media all the
time so maybe people are tagging him and
send it to him so he's probably like man
this sucks keep going that one's done
that was it that's all I saw but I heard
he got a seasoned assist
I don't know how that works yeah because
now like he's showing nude pictures he
even post a picture with her with LeBron
oh really yeah
yeah he's these kids I'm telling you man
there's no there's no boundary like
there's just when you play this game
with the Logan Paul's Jake Paul's like
that world they don't come from the
respect and [__] that I back in the day
there's just gloves are off dude so when
you sign up for this fight get ready for
these young kids it's like when Daniel's
talking trash to Jake Paul it's like
it's literally all he does dude he's
gonna light you up which he did yeah
it's just what they do they have their
black belt in it you know yeah
uh tough fight for Dylan
yeah you would assume because he doesn't
really box you know but
who knows
no I think I think Logan Paul destroys
them yeah maybe I think maybe I I don't
know yeah who knows but that's an
interesting fight that's coming up
um did you see this clip of uh
so Anthony Joshua fought over the
weekend that one guy would talk about
Helen's helensky or hello ski whatever
ko'd him and then Conor McGregor is in
the ring and gave him a pint of his
Stout oh Jester probably knows it's like
for advertising yeah but Connor just
looks crazy I don't know if Josh would
drinks yeah he didn't even want it it
looked like he didn't even want to be
there with Connor but he just like I had
to do it
I did it was like all right man
yeah
it's kind of going bald a little bit
yeah oh wow he's definitely like this
little light up top yeah
it happens man yeah Connor does his
thing you know he's just like full-blown
salesman now
and he's just so funny to watch I saw
Casey too I see every Conor post Casey
likes every single post because it's so
crazy all the random posts are so crazy
yeah when she shows some magic chin I'm
never telling you guys again
uh so we knew this was gonna happen
pretty much but it's official now Israel
Sonya versus Sean Strickland 293. love
that fight
it's not so much the style of the fight
like the actual fight hopefully the only
shame is there's not the build up I
think we're still gonna get it because
we're still what three weeks out
is it three weeks September 9th yeah
it's about three weeks
September 9th damn so how many weeks is
that she brought up a calendar I know
I'm doing so one
two yeah three weeks almost no it's four
no so you have this week one two four
yeah it's only Monday so you have four
weeks oh we can get build up because you
know strictly gonna bring that fire talk
I mean it's gonna be uncomfortable the
UFC's oh God yeah and ESPN Disney's like
oh this is really the guy fighting he's
like yeah dude it comes with the fury
that's why we're ready for it and you
said if he does win oh my God that
champion
yeah UFC's gonna the sponsor Mike hey
man we're just not gonna work with you
anymore just don't talk which I like I
like when there's Mayhem I you know for
for these corporations it's gonna be
great but uh you know we'll get to it
the week of the fight but stylistically
nightmare for Strickland across the
board
but I'm more excited about the build up
than I am the actual fight if they let
Sean Strickland do his thing I wonder if
they try to put the shackles on
Strickland
and I'll like not do so much but they're
going to I'm sure
I'm sure people would tell them like
come on just chill out good luck they've
tried I know his managers like to eat
and you know we've tried it's just what
he does and that's one of the reasons
you love Sean yeah it's what's dope
about it yeah I can't wait for that
build up
hahaha uh have you seen this footage of
Jon Jones training with Gordon Ryan no I
know they're trained together first team
all skinny legs
both of them it looks pretty dope the
way Jon Jones
wrestles him
[Music]
hmm what do you think
um I don't think they're going full go
there that was like a full thing that
was more for the cameras
okay and it is from Jon Jones's
Instagram stuff yeah but that's dope
John's working with him yeah
two [__] to The Best of the Best Man Two
Goats going at it definitely ain't
grappling too
so Tom aspinall says that he's going to
help Tyson Fury
train for it yeah why wouldn't he since
I have no loyalties to Francis because
he doesn't know him it's not like he's
dissing him he just doesn't know him I
don't think he's ever been I don't get
why this is even a headline I know the
headline is he's fellow englishmen's
helping fellow Englishmen prepare yeah
for a fight
did he have to have no lawyer to France
why would you because they're both in
the UFC so they were on UFC alumni
visiting podcasting and they're like you
know they're just asking about it
because they have no loyalty he's just
he just means he's he's not friends with
him he doesn't never met him Francis out
he's fighting with his countrymen also I
don't know how Tom Asimov
helps Fury get ready for Francis
Styles and it's not yeah he's not a
boxer necessarily uh
as far as straight up fundamentals a box
and Tom's probably more crisp boxer than
Francis he's just that power I mean if
I'm pure I just do my regular Camp bring
it bring in some wild
Brawlers now Tom Aspen all his
technique's almost too good oh yeah he
needs some Brawlers
swing yeah yeah Francis he's not going
to sit back and try and pick you apart
it's gonna be a brawl you need to bring
in some big heavy-handed mofos try and
land that shot and you got to navigate
it
that's where that's even a headline
all right uh here's another one so
Federal a milliona was on aerial show at
Mar and then uh he's saying that he
would like to box Mike Tyson and he
would like to do it under that same card
if Tyson was down because Tyson's
already training um yeah
um yeah but I but Mike Tyson done like
real fights like he did you know I mean
they had accidentally Roy Jones wanted
to do it in favor if they're like yeah
it's exhibition he's like what what's
that wait I can't try and take his head
off like no no he's like I'm not doing
that so that Mike Tyson never agreed to
that they put Jake Paul he doubts Jake
but why would Jake Paul fight it was
insane how is this even a headline uh
how's this the fact that he wants to
even like do this is already kind of
trippy like the Mike Tyson one makes
sense you got two goats one of box and
one of MMA Fedor Mike Dyson I love it
two older dudes if we knew it was a real
fight hell yeah take my money but it's
gonna be that weird like Roy Jones Jr
thing don't waste my time or your time
doubts Jake Paul would willing to fight
him Ah that's even a headliner question
I blows my mind
uh yeah so anyway he wants to box Tyson
I think their age yeah
um so this is just a quick one
during the uh Joshua thing he was uh
Connor was interviewed by I think uh
was it Mac live someone anyway he said
that he's returning
in December to fight Chandler he's going
to fight Chandler first and then he's
going to do the BMF belt with Justin
gaichi and then finish it off for the
trilogy with names damn that'd be great
great way to end your career that's all
I think that's all those are especially
the Chandler fight 100 is happening it's
a big if he can win that fight
the only way you get gauges if you beat
Chandler otherwise that gate sheet makes
no sense and then even if we were to
lose both those fights which I think
he's probably going to get the trailer
fight but even for you to lose a
challenge that Nate Diaz Trilogy is not
going anywhere they can do that whenever
the one that's up for the air would be
gaichi you'd have to beat Jalen to fight
gechi
otherwise there's zero point to do it I
mean yeah you can't fight for the BMF
title when you've won one fight in six
years
his name yeah so
yeah anyway so the rumors about you
potentially fighting Derek Lewis right
if he puts if he was able to leave the
UFC but apparently he's now signed a new
eight fight deal with UFC smart man yeah
there you go good good for everybody all
around good for Derek Lewis good for my
health
nice try nice try Jorge
that's all I saw uh uh dirkland's coach
at the fights too Eric Nixon right yeah
no no no no Derek Lewis's coach yeah
Nixon's Francis yeah I thought
so this is a story about Francis as well
um I think it was the most recent fight
that happened it was fight night they
put this guy said only cameroonian fire
in the UFC history yeah but they're
they're wrong because Francis was in the
first either so could you yeah so so
Francis posted this too so could you was
a first and then Francis was a second
again how is UFC such a big Corporation
how do you get this stuff but he's
thinking they're doing it on purpose
though I don't think so I think you're
you're getting too much credit I just
think I just think they don't know the
lay of the land in Africa and just
really [__] up and he thinks it's all
personal I don't think so because this
is a knock on sokaju
I remember I saw like
the video of like a promotion video from
UFC and they showed an Asian fighter but
they had it his name was a different
Asian fighter but it was just yeah it's
racist I mean whatever they just don't
know yeah if you think whoever's making
this stuff knows the lay of the land in
Africa and which fighters from which
country you're out of your mind they
should yeah but you know
you got young kids in there probably
don't know UFC history so everyone knows
soak Jew was the first one
was a mother he was a badass in the very
beginning that everybody knows a little
bit what'd you say oh yeah oh yeah but
he was a he was a killer in the
beginning yeah I used to train with that
rain monster dude yeah physically a
monster monster that reminds me of the
Reebok deal too when they started all
the misspellings and they it was
horrible yeah yeah if you know what
you're doing
um this is this is fun yeah so Craig
Jones amazing BJJ guy he's going to be
one of the best yeah doing a match with
Rick I think people would be surprised
how good Luke rockhold is at grappling
he's so good he just never does in MMA
and this is what Craig Craig Jones
posted never in history coming sports
have two dime pieces of this caliber
locked horns
I've lost I've often been told I need
Jesus in my life with an opportunity to
hit Jerusalem in search of him so that's
where they're doing it at
that'll be fun yeah it's a cool one
um
okay so you posted this on your I think
your Twitter or Instagram as well so
Zuckerberg versus Elon Musk Zuckerberg
said that he's our he's been trying like
legitimately trying to get this fight
done but it seems like Elon Musk is just
all talk right yeah I don't think it's
happening
I said that from the jump
yeah so Zuck but I think we can all
agree Elon isn't serious and it's time
to move on I've offered a real date do
you know why I often make this a legit
competition for charity Elon won't
confirm a date and says he needs surgery
and now has to do a practice round in my
backyard instead if Elon ever gets
serious about a real date and official
event he knows how to reach me otherwise
time to move on I'm going to focus on
competing with people who take this
sport seriously
what's up with Jeff Bezos
because I don't see Zuck fight like you
know legit Fighters like let's let's go
for these big big boys what's Bill Gates
do I'd love to see him chunk out Bill
Gates shady ass yeah but Bill Gates has
no way in shape for that but what's up
with Alex Jones and Alex Jones Zuck
fight wasn't Alex a wrestler too I think
he was in high school or something like
that I don't think so I think so I don't
think so dude
um here's just a
interesting one this Dan hooker started
getting tattoos recently yeah his whole
legs right yeah so this is his chest
piece and then his legs are because that
chest piece is intense his legs are so
dope so jealous of those the chess piece
is interesting
yeah so intense good work though
and this is just a funny picture is Alex
Alex Bahia on a ride I think this is at
a Disneyland it shows no emotions
everyone I saw him post he's like had a
great time at whatever Disney World
that's his thing right yeah
yeah I think that's it dude all right
dude
so just uh yeah 292 that's it yep enjoy
UFC 292 this Saturday in Boston baby you
got a stacked main card undercard's good
as well The Ultimate Fighter finale
Austin Hubbard you got Andre petrovski
Gerald mercert uh Chris Weidman Brad
Tavares Marlon Cheeto Vera Pedro Munoz
Ian Machado Gary Neal magni wayle Amanda
limos aljo and sugar Sean take my
freaking money UFC it's a great UFC 292
this Saturday in Boston it's going down
enjoy the fights thanks for watching
this show listening review get your
podcasts at and like subscribe do the
thing all the kids tell you to do all
right kids I'll see you around be nice
to each other until next time I'm out